[Music]
good morning everybody
and welcome to rockefeller university's
virtual science saturday
i am jeannie garberino director of rocky
to you science outreach
and i'm the host today pay attention to
my background photos because i'm going
to share examples of past sign saturday
events
through my pictures before getting
started i would like to thank our
generous sponsors who have made science
saturday possible
they are the andreas c drakopolis family
science and society initiative
the quadrivium foundation the percent
freeman family
and the styman family foundation before
i introduce you to our experts on
microscopes i'd like to tell you a bit
about myself
and what my job at rockefeller is all
about
as a kid i always loved to ask questions
about nature
and how things worked in fact one of my
first science memories is using the
microscope kit my parents gave to me
as a gift it helped me begin to explore
the world of science
and once i began learning about the
incredible tools that scientists can
build
just to answer questions about the world
i was totally hooked
from a very early age probably since the
age of
many of you out there i knew i wanted to
become a scientist
while i think everyone can be a
scientist in their own way
i was really lucky to get formal
scientific training at columbia
university which is a college
or a university on the upper west side
of manhattan
and i studied how molecules of fat
behave
inside of our cells you might think of
fat like things like butter
or olive oil but there's molecules of
fat that are very important for our
cells to function
and when i finished those studies i
passed a special test
and i was granted an educational degree
called a phd
getting this degree allowed me to get a
new kind of science position
this time as a postdoctoral researcher
at rockefeller
where i continue to study how fat
molecules behave inside of cells
over time i realized that i was just as
passionate about sharing the wonders of
science as i was at
doing science and that led to my
becoming a
director of rocky to use science
outreach at rockefeller
this is really my dream job because i
get to share all of the cool science
that is going on at rockefeller
with students and teachers in new york
city and beyond
each year my team and i run lab programs
for thousands of new york city students
and teachers
who are involved in the k-12 educational
sphere
in these sessions sometimes students
spend the day with us seeing what is
like to conduct science in a lab
and during the summer we work with high
school students and college students
who are paired with rockfiller
scientists to work on special research
projects
you can find more about all of these
programs on our
edu website on the rockefeller
university website
rockefeller is a really exciting place
to work
sometimes i think about rockefeller in
terms of pop culture
like you know how amazing disney world
is and how all of the stories that come
out of disney and pixar are
just always so much fun well that is how
i feel about rockefeller
being on campus is like being at disney
world and learning the knowledge that
our scientists create
is like watching the best pixar movie
ever
at rockefeller we have 600 scientists
working in 70 different labs
we call the bosses of the labs principal
investigators
which we often shorten to pi that's sort
of like a cool title you know like the
pi
and as the boss of the lab the pi runs a
team
of staff like research technicians and
trainees
like graduate students and post-docs i
was a postdoc so i was a trainee
under a boss that was called the pi
science is truly a huge team effort
through these efforts we study almost
every disease or health condition you
can think of
and are guided by our motto science for
the benefit of humanity
so i told you about the
players in the research laboratory but
while each scientist is an expert in
their field
no scientist can be an expert in
everything
and often a scientist from a lab needs
cutting-edge
high-tech complex equipment to help with
their research
so at rockefeller resource centers have
been set up to house
specialized equipment and experts have
been hired to help scientists with their
investigations
and most the time the experts are
scientists themselves
resource centers are super important for
supporting science research
and this morning you're going to meet
the specialists who run
two microscope centers i bet many of you
have seen a microscope and maybe even
operated one
maybe you got a gift from someone who
cared about you
the way i did uh when i got a microscope
present from my family
as you can imagine microscopes are
powerful tools because they enable
scientists to discover things about our
world
that we cannot see with our eyes alone
when did we start using microscopes you
may not know
that the first microscope was invented
hundreds of years ago
early on scientists use microscopes to
study biology
such as what are flowers and leaves made
of or
what are microbes like bacteria and
yeast and what are they doing
in our in our life but since their
invention
microscopes continue to evolve back then
microscopes
let us see cells today there are
microscopes that let us look
inside of cells and even inside
molecules
to see individual atoms which are the
basic building blocks of all
living things there are also microscopes
that you can put in your pocket
and others that stand on the floor are
taller than a person
and weigh hundreds of pounds we are
going to see one of these today
and after we've heard from all the
presenters we will take
questions from the audience we already
have a list of questions that were sent
in
and if you have a question please feel
free to use the q
a function at the bottom of your screen
to type in your question and we'll try
to get as
many as we can okay
now i am so so excited to
introduce a couple of my favorite people
at rockefeller
it is my great pleasure to introduce dr
allison north
a research associate professor and the
senior director of the fritz
and rita marcus bio imaging resource
center i
also like to call her the queen of
microscopy
and joining her is donovan a graduate
fellow
um who is all who does a ton of
microscopy in his own work
welcome allison and donovan i'm now
turning the program
over to you thank you so much so good to
be here with you today
good morning everybody welcome to the
bio imaging resource center
can everyone hear me maybe jean you can
stick your thumb up if you can hear us
fine
yeah you're you're coming in great
excellent good
so it's my pleasure to tell you today
about what we do
here in the bio imaging resource center
and as genie said i've brought in
donovan who's one of the scientists who
uses our microscopes
we're doing something incredibly brave
today we're doing a live demo
that's a very risky thing to do with a
half million dollar microscope which
tends to crash frequently
this one has quite a strong personality
of its own
it also needs a little bit of tweaking
but since it was made in the uk
the engineers have not been able to get
out during covid
so just like the cooking shows we've
made some movies in advance just in case
things go wrong
we're going to hope they don't so what
we do here in the bio imaging center is
we use
optical microscopes which are also known
as light microscopes
so what i mean by that is just any
microscopes which use visible
wavelengths of light
for the illumination and most of the
microscopes that we use here
are actually fluorescence microscopes so
i want to explain quickly what
fluorescence is
so certain types of molecules can
undergo this process called fluorescence
and what that means is
that if you shine a certain color or
wavelength of light at these molecules
they can get excited into a higher
energy state
and then they kind of vibrate around and
this higher energy state for a while
like you do if you've had too much
chocolate
and then after a while they drop back
down again to their normal state and as
they do that
they release what we call a photon of
light of a different color that's the
cool part so you excite them with one
color and they emit a different longer
wavelength
color right so this is just to show you
what it would look like for example
we could excite a tube of dark colored
liquid with blue light in it a mix green
light
cool okay then
so why is this clever well one thing we
can do
is we can use glass filters actually
they're generally made of
hundreds of layers of coatings these
expensive little filters can cost
hundreds of dollars each
and we can use these to separate out
different colors of light
so now we could say have one color and
then
a different color and a different color
all at once how cool is that
i want to give you a little
demonstration of fluorescence we're
going to see if this will work
and i've got a very very high power uv
laser pointer here
which is highly dangerous so i'm going
to warn donovan to please not look round
for the next few seconds
because we do not want to risk damaging
his eyes which we could easily do
if you look over there at that there's a
black box on the table next to the
microscope
i'm going to shine this uv lazy and
hopefully you can see a purple dot there
and if i move that purple dot across
onto the liquid now you can see
it turns blue okay
so this uv light is exciting a certain
fluorochrome we call it a fluorescent
molecule which then emits this blue
colored light
now normally if you were here in person
i would ask does anybody anyone tell me
what this is because it's the first
known fluorescent molecule that was
identified back in the mid-1800s
i can tell you your parents are probably
very familiar with it they put it in
their
gin this is quinine or quinine as they
pronounce it in this country which is
found in tonic water
so that's all that's in that bottle so
anyway
that's what we can do and the cool thing
about fluorescence is as you saw there
you get a very very bright dot
against a very black background so it's
a very
high contrast technique as we would say
if you want to see something in a
microscope you need it to be
easily distinguishable against what's in
the background contrast is very
important
the other thing that's very important in
microscopes is
not what you all think you're all
thinking magnification
actually the answer is resolution and
what do i mean by resolution i mean it's
the ability to have
two very closely spaced objects but be
able to perceive that they're actually
two separate objects not just one bigger
object
and when you see the next talk about
electron microscopes you're going to say
well my goodness they have much better
resolution
than a light microscope why not would
anybody bother devoting their entire
life to like microscopy them anymore
well the answer is we can do something
very cool with light microscopes we can
image
living organisms that you can't do with
an electron microscope so each of them
has their uses
so how do we image living organisms well
some years ago they discovered the
protein that makes
a certain jellyfish called aquaria
victoria flores green
the protein is known as very originally
green fluorescent
protein so this is actually won the
nobel prize all this work
what they did was they isolated the dna
that encodes this green fluorescent
protein
and then what we can do is we can take
the dna which encodes any protein
that you're interested in looking at and
following around the cell
so now what we do is we use i hope you
can see this the dna
for the gfp with the dna for the protein
and we end up with this
dna this one strip which contains both
of them
and now it's going to express it as a
protein that has a little tiny green for
us attack
so we can do that with this gfp from um
from jellyfish we can also do it with
different color fluorescent proteins
from corals if you want to find the
coolest job in the universe
it's not actually genies it's the person
i heard from in australia
whose entire job is to go scuba diving
at night
to find different colors of fluorescent
corals and then bring them up into the
lab the next day so if you like scuba
diving and science
there's the job for you so we can take
this green breast of protein
we can tag all different parts of the
cells and that's what donovan's going to
show you
we can even tag entire green fluorescent
rabbit for example it's completely
harmless it doesn't affect it
or here you can see this is from what
they call the rainbow
mouse which is a mouse which has
different colors of fluorescent protein
and all the different neurons in its
brain
super cool right so now we have these
so how do we image them so we put them
under a microscope
so here you have a kind of microscope
here that we would use
this is a very fancy one actually this
is called a super resolution microscope
which means it can
give you better resolution than most
like microscopes
what we have is the regular microscope
and then we have here is there this box
which looks incredibly boring right but
it's not inside that box
is actually a whole load of fancy
lenses and mirrors i'm showing you this
but i'm not really allowed to because of
the intellectual property so i'm just
whisking it in front of your eyes
so just to say it's really complicated
and coming into the back of the
microscope
we have lasers coming in through a fiber
optic cable
and then the light comes out through
here through this fancy box and then it
reaches two different cameras here
on the end these cameras can cost up to
sixty thousand dollars each by the way
they're
very very sensitive so you can detect a
single molecule
of this fluorescence we also have
another laser coming into the back of
the microscope which is actually
short wavelength very high power pulse
and it's used for cutting things it's
like a pair of scissors
in the back of the microscope we call
this absolution
so we can go in and we can just cut
something very precisely in the cell
and this is something that you're going
to see donovan do it so this microscope
is super fast it's super resolution
it's incredibly sensitive and it's
really exciting to use
when it's working so now we're going to
pray and i'm going to hand over at this
point to donovan
who's going to take it away with the
science hey guys how's it going
i'm donovan of your i'm a graduate
student here at rockefeller university
um and i'm really excited to tell you
about what i'm working on and things
that we can do with the microscope here
so just like you and i we all have
trillions of cells inside our body
and in these cells we have muscles so
just like
you're you're just like your brain cell
your liver cell your muscle cell
inside all these cells they have little
little muscles and bones we call the
cytoskeleton
and so i'm really interested in
understanding how the muscle works in
these cells
so using the green fluorescent protein
like thousands have mentioned before
we can label the cytoskeleton of the
cell or the muscles of the cell
as i play the movie you can watch these
cells move around and explore its
territory so you can see some of it is
squirming
squeezing its muscles somebody moving
back
you know some of it's protruding out and
so i'm really really excited and really
interested in understanding
how these scale how the cytoskeleton in
the cell works more specifically
just like you and i um our cells our
muscles can get cramps
so when you get cramps you feel tired
you're less likely to move or you don't
want to work as hard
the same thing for these cells the cells
can get cramps too and how we can watch
these cells
um have cramps or watch whether they
have a cramp is by this protein called
six sin so let me show you that real
quick
so here i'm using two labeled two two
different proteins that are fluorescent
labels so an orange i have labeled
um the cytoskeleton or the muscles of
the cell and then green is this protein
we call zixin it's green
and it actually will label and find
areas
of the muscle which is under a cramp so
to speak so if you watch this
screen over here this is where i overlay
the two colors together and you can
watch
everything happen so here you can see
on occasion you will have an area where
it must
of one of one of the muscles of the
cells will have a little crimp and you
can see this green protein
come and say oh here's the cramp and so
i'm really really
understanding well this protein knows
where the cramp is and then later on it
actually knows how to teach
how to tell the cell to fix the crown
and so i'm really interested in
understanding how do you fix a cramp how
do you heal a cramp
and so one way of doing it is by using
this powerful light microscope
to collect lifestyle images of movies
of the cell making cramps and healing
itself another powerful way of doing it
is actually using
as alice mentioned um this laser just
like in star wars you can shoot a laser
through
throughout a cell and cut it up and by
cutting it up it's just like you
imagining to
create a little cramp in itself so we're
going to now do that and i'm going to
show you
um actually live in live um how we can
cut up a cell
to watch this little flash like right
over here you can see
the screen pop up how that could happen
live all right
so first off i just want to make sure my
cells are there this is my cell this is
part of the cells way bigger than the
screen as possible but here it is
and just for fun i'm going to show you
green okay so this is now this in green
is
um it's extended i talked about earlier
the protein that labels where all the
cramps are
and now i'm going to create a spot for
where i want to um
create the cramp and actually i'm going
to use in this case i'm going to use
this one
so to make a cramp all i have to do is
say
you know i really want to cut up let's
see like this part of the cell and i'll
draw a little circle right here
and i'm going to make that the region
where i want to cut the cell
and we'll go ahead and start cutting it
up so this is going to be image and this
is basically my control panel it's like
a big like running a spaceship over here
so i'm about to start the laser ablation
and here you're going to watch i'm going
to overlap just to get it over here for
everyone
you should be able to see that it starts
to flash i'm going to show that
real quick okay wrong one sorry i'm
sorry sorry
you can see probably in the left panel
that there's like a dark hole where he
hit it with a laser very exciting and
you can see that that hole is getting
bigger so he clearly cut a hole in it
yeah so i'm gonna i'm gonna show you
exactly where i
uh cut it right right here right and
actually what's nice about this we can
actually collect movies so
i can play this over and over again you
can watch just as where i cut it
you see that little orange spot go away
you'll start seeing the green should
come up slowly
sometimes the crep is sometimes i shoot
it so hard that that cell
it realizes oh my gosh this cramp is so
bad that i just can't
i can't live with it anymore i'm gonna
let my muscle go and say better luck
another time
so i can turn it up here and maybe you
can see the cramped water
so you can see how as i'm collecting
actually each movie here we're playing
over and over again because
we're collecting every five seconds of
the movie of the cell watching what
happens so
sometimes it takes instantly a couple
seconds in this case it's a bit small
but you can see in this case it happens
in the matter of probably
30 seconds and 30 seconds there's a
cramp and the cell will notice to where
the cramp is and i can cut it up and
show where that cramp is showing
smaller but it's still noticeable in
this case that's so cool
yep that's it so i just have to
interject here and say that
where genie says that she always knew
that she wanted to be in science i can't
say that because i nearly became a
professional musician
but i can say that the first time i
looked through a fluorescence microscope
that was a point i knew that that is
exactly what i wanted to do with my
career
and so that's why i specialized in it
and the fun for me is that i get to work
with all of these different people with
all of these exciting projects
who come in and use the microscopes to
ask different questions
sometimes i'll be imaging something once
every 30 minutes
for like a week at a time and you won't
see the result
until the very end of it so you have to
be a very patient person
well sometimes you have something that's
exciting like what donovan's doing here
where you just
almost instantly see a result and
sometimes things change so quickly
that we can hardly capture them on the
cameras and that's why we need faster
and
faster
and more expensive cameras
how many times have you zoomed in on
this donovan what's the objective
um yeah you're using so this is this is
a 100 x 100 x
so it's a hundred times more zoomed in
um
and so you're you're basically this 100x
is probably
the highest one of the highest
magnification magnifications you can get
for a light microscope
um so yeah it's really zoomed up and so
you can
watch slowly over time there's there's a
very light but you still noticeable
there's over time as you can deflate the
cell and i'll stop i'll do a one
frame by frame for you guys so you watch
the circle oops went backwards
you watch the frame you can watch as i
slowly inflate as soon as i apply you
can watch
and watch the any screen you want goes
the wrong way
watch any screen you want as soon as you
play you can see that there's a
spot where oh the stress fibers or the
cytoskeleton
goes away you get a big cramp and as you
do that there's green that pops up right
in that circle
and sometimes it's really small and
sometimes it's really big
um and that's just basically on how big
the cramp is
and how the cell can begin to repair
this ground
super cool and are the is this uh so we
have a question around whether or not
these cells are dead but they are not
dead correct no no we're looking at them
they're living their life on this glass
on a piece of glass
trying to figure out where they are
because we just you know yeah we started
shooting
with lasers like oh my gosh what's
happening now you're not making me like
not be able to walk what's wrong you
know
and so um it's right now it's just
trying to figure its life out but yeah
we do this all the time and
that's the power of the light microscope
you can actually watch live with what is
happening
um you know over seconds of of the time
scale
um whether it's getting a crimp or not
how you can repair the cramp and so
forth
so here we're looking at cells we have
other microscopes where we actually look
at
living organisms you can even have
we have one where you can even just
shape out a little bit of the braid like
that
the mouse the um cell and i've got a
little glass window there
and you can watch what's going on in the
neurons of these nights and they're
they're alive it's fine it's just like
one of us having an operation
for these techniques can be pretty
non-invasive and they're they're being
used more and more as well by doctors in
medicine particularly if you can have
fiber-optic ways of delivering the light
you can imagine for example if you're
trying to cut out tumors
and you want to see whether you've got
the whole tumor out wouldn't it be much
better if you could just look straight
away
in the person and use the breast light
targeted to see whether you've got out
all the energy
so these are the kind of tools that have
been developed now so there are a whole
range of different microscopes that we
have here
the ones that are used for bacteria once
again
the whole um zebrafish or worms
once it be used for cells and everyone
requires its own
specific setup they're all slightly
different from each other we have around
18 of them and they range from about
100 000 to just over a billion dollars
i know we love watching these movies
over and over again but i just want to
show you one last one
where you can watch this region right
here where i can upload where i can
again use a laser to shoot and cut up a
cell
and you can watch how this this happens
a cramp happens here and then you see a
big flash of green
right like watch all these other things
happening and watch
you know this other large part of the
muscle fusing with each other
as you have cramps so that's the part of
line right you see so much happening at
one time and you know exactly what
you're looking at because you label or
you
specifically color your protein of
interest so that's what i study i study
how cells make cramps and how we can
heal these cramps
awesome thank you these are this is
super cool thank you so much both
all right um yeah yeah
let's get let's let's thanks the light
microscopes are awesome i'll never
forget
um having allison teach me to use some
of the microscopes in my studies and how
there was one time i was able to take my
cells
and put them in this chamber so that the
temperature was kept
um you know at the right temperature and
the right carbon dioxide level was sort
of maintained and i was able to watch
and set up movies of my cells to learn
about how things were taking place over
time
and looking through that microscope was
some of the coolest things i've i've
ever seen in my life
um so thank you so much and we'll come
back to you both in a little bit but
we're gonna
head on over to the cryo-em facility to
say hello
so um johanna and han kit please
join us today turn on turning on your
videos and
just say hello we're so excited to have
our next stop be the evelyn gruss lipper
cryo electron microscopy resource center
i'm so pleased to introduce you to our
expert johanna sothires
and hong ken who helped run the center
they have put together a video about the
big powerful
microscopes and how they operate but
before we see that video
tell us how you're doing today both
oh well thank you it's uh it's a rainy
saturday but we're happy to be here
awesome i see great and you both are
donning your tie dye as for your science
saturday
yes so science saturday we all wear
tie-dye shirts and that's how you can
identify
the scientists so hopefully you'll see
us next time on
campus um so
all right i need to know we talked a
little bit about like what we saw and
how awesome
those things you know seeing things
under light microscopes right
and you work with a different kind of
microscope but i want to know you must
have had experience with microscope for
years what is the coolest thing
you have ever seen under a microscope
johanna why don't you tell us first sure
yeah well um
i would have to say um it was
using a a scanning electron microscope
which is
um i dip well a different type
of electron microscope than what we use
here which are transmission electron
microscopes
and we use this microscope to look at a
zebrafish
and the zebrafish we actually zoomed in
inside the ear canal of the
zebrafish and we visualize tiny tiny
tiny little hair color folds inside the
ear come out
and i thought that was amazing wow that
was one of my most
memorable experiences using these
microscopes
cool i'm getting goose bumps that's so
cool
how about you kid uh for me it was also
scanning like my true
microscope oh sorry scan
electromicroscope um but it would
instead of saying biological it was
actually graphite so the stuff that
we used to make our uh pencils it looks
very solid
to our naked eye at least um but when
you look at it under electron microscope
you see
all the striations all of the little
imperfections that kind of
cause it to be such a good writing
utensil like it just flakes off onto the
paper
i thought that was really cool there
were a lot of like really small little
like
probably crystals like balls of uh
of graphite and other striations i just
look really cool
that sounds awesome all right i have one
extremely
serious question i really need you to
get into a serious mindset
okay what is your favorite ice cream
flavor
well i'm a bit of a traditional person i
like chocolate
and i'll stick to that yeah purist
how about you honk it uh for me it would
be um
probably uh child chipper oh yeah
that's a good one my favorite though
yeah
i remember when cookie dough was
introduced to the world and it changed
my life
yes exactly great
well i think um these were very
important introductions that we had to
share with our audience before moving
in um but let's uh
what are we going to take a look at now
johanna do you want to just tell us
a quick uh introduction of of what we're
about to see
absolutely yes so this is a mini tour
of our facility here at the cryolic
microscopy resource center we're going
to see our transmission electron
microscopes
and our newest addition which is will be
introduced by haunted
our focused ion beam electron microscope
and
we also have some cryo um
like a light microscopy uh capabilities
as well
so please enjoy cool awesome all right
well
let's let's take a look at the video
welcome to the cryoelectrum microscopy
resource center
our facility has three transmission
electron microscopes
a 200 000 volt talos arctica seen here
and two 300 000 volt titan cryosis seen
here
what is the transmission electron
microscope a tm
is built similarly as a light microscope
if you look at this figure
you see for both systems there is an
elimination source
a stage where the sample sits and a
series of lenses that focus
magnify and project an image but in the
case of the tm
the illumination source are electrons
and not photons
and instead of glass lenses the tm has
electromagnetic lenses
why do we use electrons and not photons
think about what the human eye can
resolve that means
how close can two objects be to each
other and still be able to distinguish
them from one another
so let's say the human eye can resolve
objects separated by
0.2 millimeters conventional light
microscope
can resolve objects separated by .0002
millimeters or
200 nanometers the electron microscope
can resolve objects separated by
look at so many zeros in our case that's
close to two angstroms that's the unit
of measurement we use in electron
microscopy
this is very important in determining
the structure of small molecules such as
proteins
because if we can resolve objects
separated by only two angstroms
we can actually resolve the atoms of a
molecule
what makes electrons so good at
resolving atoms and molecules
well electrons are very very small
thousands of times smaller than atoms
electrons can also behave like waves
just like photons do
and they have wavelengths and depending
on what speed the electrons are moving
which is dependent on what we call the
accelerating voltage of the microscope
the electron wavelengths can be made
very small
making the resolving power much better
let's take a closer look inside the
microscope
this is our electron gun this is where
the electrons are extracted from a
special metal filament
and then accelerated down the column
this is our camera an extremely
sensitive image sensor
it is sensitive enough to detect
individual electrons when an electron
hits the sensor the signal it produces
is read out to form an image
this is where we load our samples and we
can load up to 12 samples at a time
there's a robotic arm that manipulates
the grid and loads it onto the stage
the microscope although large and heavy
is very sensitive to vibrations
therefore it sits on an anti-vibration
table which isolates it
from any environmental disturbances this
is our high tension tank
this is where we produce the high
voltage needed to accelerate the
electrons
close to the speed of light the
microscope needs to be under vacuum
otherwise the electron beam would be
disrupted by air molecules
the system also has to be very cold
that's why we use liquid nitrogen to
cool it down to minus 320 degrees
fahrenheit
this is to protect our sample from
radiation damage caused by high energy
electrons
let's take a closer look at how we
prepare these samples
our microscopes are very large measuring
up to 13 feet tall
but our sample that goes into the
microscope must be very small
just three millimeters in diameter i'm
preparing the grid for freezing by
securing it onto fine tipped tweezers
that will be secured onto our grid
plunger
we use liquid ethane as our coolant
our sample volume is also very small
only three microliters
the sample is in a solution that
contains hundreds of thousands of
identical copies of protein molecules
we add the protein solution onto the
grid
but even three microliters is too much
for the microscope
so using special papers we wick off
about 97
of the solution and leave a very thin
film of sample under the grid
this thin film of sample is flash frozen
in liquid ethane and forms a glass-like
frozen layer
in which the protein particles are
frozen in different orientations
here is a schematic enlargement of what
the grid looks like
it is divided by hundreds of little
squares and each square has a thin layer
of carbon support film
and arranged in a matrix are 1.2 micron
diameter holes that are empty
inside these holes our sample is frozen
the frozen grids are too thin and
vulnerable to be loaded directly into
the microscope
so before we load them we assemble them
into what we call a cartridge
the cartridge consists of three parts
the ring the grid and a c-clip
seen here this is our cassette
it can fit up to 12 cartridges
everything is under liquid nitrogen
we do not want our sample to melt at any
point
the cassette is then transferred into a
pre-cooled capsule
now we're ready to take our samples to
the microscope
now we're docking the capsule onto the
autoloader
a valve opens and a mechanical arm goes
into the capsule and grabs the cassette
you can see some liquid nitrogen being
displaced
the arm goes back up
and the valve closes
and the capsules released
[Music]
the technique we use is called single
particle analysis
we collect thousands of 2d images of the
protein molecules caught in different
orientations
a sophisticated computer algorithm
stitches the images together
to reveal a three-dimensional structure
now we're going to hear from honkit
this protein looks big but in reality it
is about 6 000 times smaller than the
thickness of the hair
there are millions of proteins like
these in the cell but what if you want
to see directly inside the cell to find
this protein
these microscopes cannot do this because
cells are way too thick for electrons to
pass through them so to get around this
we can cut the cells
using another microscope to start cells
are frozen on a grid and taken to a
fluorescent microscope
we start by cooling down the transfer
station and loading our grids onto a
shuttle which we put inside of the scope
this microscope uses light not electrons
to look inside the cell
the proteins we're interested in are
marked with tiny tags that glow under
certain light conditions
and we can use this information to tell
us where we should be cutting the cell
each glowing green dot is the location
of our protein
after these locations are marked we can
load them into the actual cutting
microscope
to do this we have to cool down another
transfer station and load the grids onto
another shuttle to put inside of the
scope
this time the microscope is an electron
microscope with an ion beam attached
the ion beam is similar to a very
powerful laser and we will use this to
cut the cells to make them thin enough
for us to see inside
using locations we got from the
fluorescence microscope we can target
the areas where a protein is located
and cut thin sideways slices of the cell
after everything is set up we start the
ion beam and watch as the cell melts
away until there is only a thin layer
left
this video is sped up but this process
can take up to an hour to complete
and has to be done at least four or more
times to get them to be thin enough
this mound is the front view of a cell
before we cut it
and here is the cell after we cut it
leaving only a thin piece of cellular
material at the center of the cell
once the cells are cut we will take the
grits the transmission electron
microscopes
and take images of the cell and that's
it
hopefully you all enjoyed our
presentation on these different types of
microscopes
thank you so much yohanna and han kit i
think we
are now going to be joined by alison
and donovan and start getting to
everybody's questions
um we have a bunch of questions coming
in through the chat we also have some
questions that were
submitted upon registration and i think
that they are
great so thank you everybody um anybody
who continues
developing a question throughout this
discussion please feel free to drop it
into the q
a um all right
so let's get started
uh i think maybe this question
could be good for johanna since you work
with
such a uh with a microscope with such a
high
resolution we have a question from ilya
and they wonder what is the smallest
object you can see with a microscope
well uh that would be adam's um
uh actually we have a special sample
that we load onto our microscope and we
use that to
fine-tune the microscope before we start
a session
and um it's sputtered or covered
with gold um particles
and we can actually resolve bold atoms
using these microscopes unfortunately we
cannot do that with biological samples
because they are sensitive to radiation
and when we image them we produce
noisier images that are not as
clear as let's say looking at old atoms
but we can resolve atoms
and following up on that uh maybe honkit
you can tell us
um a little bit about why everything has
to be frozen
when you're working with your samples
and this is a question that we
got recently from hassini
yeah so relaying back to what johannes
said um
well one of the things about biological
samples is
they need they need to be in this sort
of like aqueous solution
so the ice actually preserves that
solution when they were alive um so when
we put them actually in the microscopes
um because the microscopes are electron
microscopes they need to be in vacuum
so it's used to sort of seal everything
in place sort of like a resin
so that nothing really changes when you
put them in the scope um on top of that
whenever when you
when the electrons actually come down um
it can cause a lot of radiation damage
to the actual cells
the ice is there as a sort of like a
buffer to prevent some of that
otherwise it'll just all melt away and
get destroyed
yeah electrons electrons act like um
they're
very high energy so uh when you go to
the dentist
and they take x-rays on your teeth you
have to wear a shield
on your chest right because x-rays can
be damaging to your cells
so electrons behave similarly um as
x-rays
very high energy and can be dangerous to
biological
yeah electrons are fascinating and it's
amazing that scientists have been able
to harness them
uh as a tool for visualization so cool
um alison i'd love to ask you some
questions about
light microscopes and we have this great
question from iwana who wonders
if the light microscopes that you showed
your
your amazing fluorescent microscope is
that similar in principle to what a
student might see
in a light microscope in their schools
and how might that differ
if it is different so the kind of
microscopes
you have in your schools are probably
not fluorescent microscopes
because the fluorescent sources of light
and the cameras and so on and the lasers
whatever they're very very expensive
so in general what you'll be using in a
regular microscope in your schools is
using
white light like almost like you know
daylight almost
and so in that case there are other
techniques that you can use to impart
contrast
to your object remember i said that you
need to have contrast like
you can't see white against white right
or black against black you need to have
some kind of contrast
so there are ways of manipulating the
the light waves going through to change
the
phase of the light or the wave
paths or whatever so that you can do
these fancy ways to
impart contrast within the cells or you
can stain them there are stains that you
can put on like
hematoxylin and eosin is a classic stain
that pathologists use to stain tissue
samples so they can
see what kind of tissue you're looking
at blood vessels or
or um or all kinds of things or maybe
you'll look at a slice of um
plant tissue which already maybe has
some color in it or whatever so
in general you're just using bright
field light in in the
in in the lab but we use those
techniques as well and that's important
to
explain because those techniques are the
gentlest on cells so just in the way
that electrons can harm
tissues and cells these high power
lasers can as well
and some of the microscopes we have the
laser
the lasers are such high power that is
it's like if you're standing
in australia under the sunlight at one
o'clock in the afternoon and you don't
have sunscreen on right you're gonna
start burning so the same way the cells
will start burning
so so just using normal white light can
actually be much gentler on the cells
and it can be very very useful
and we saw an example of that donovan
right you you
used a high-powered laser to cut
a section of the cell and you call that
cutting ablation
can you tell us a little bit more about
uh where you got what were those cells
and how did you get them in the first
place yeah yeah so
those were actually called the technical
name is they're called
mouse embryonic fibroblasts so they
actually came from a mouse
um and actually when they were an embryo
stage so before they came out of there
we you call them an embryo
and um these cells were harvested from
an embryo of a mouse many many many many
years ago
um and in this case the ones i showed
you
were harvested by one of our
collaborators um and actually
this specific one we made sure to delete
a certain gene
so that we could re-express it ourselves
so
if you've heard of like crispr or some
sort of gene editing techniques that's
what we used or they had used to make
sure our mouse embryonic fibroblasts
these
these cells that you're looking at
didn't have the gene that we
re-expressed in green
so to speak awesome
and i think you know allison and johanna
as
sort of people who are working with
scientists all the time
um can you tell us about there's a
question on
how many scientists are using
microscopes at rockefeller
right and i think the number is a lot
right so yeah allison for example how
many people are using your
i'm gonna win there i know i know my
centers use more than any of the other
centers at the university
so there are about 75 laboratories at
the university let's say
and i think out of those 75 laboratories
about 70
use my facility and then we also have
about
35 laboratories from institutions
all around new york and
connecticut new jersey we've had people
coming up from baltimore
so some of our pieces of equipment are
so specialized that people will travel
a long way to come to use them and those
ones in particular are what i referred
to though when we were using the super
resolution
instrument so i did i actually did want
to expand on that because um
i have to stand up for light microscopy
what johanna
showed was absolutely true that a
standard
a standard light microscopy can only
image down to about
um 200 nanometers we'd say 0.2
micrometers
but actually the very latest super
resolution microscopes can go down to
about
two nanometers so they're actually now a
hundred times higher resolution
than they used to be so now we're
talking two nanometers for light
microscopy
and maybe 0.2 for electron microscopy
we're catching you up your hannah we're
getting there
that's good battle of the microscopy
this rivalry guys absolutely fun
yeah so johanna about how many people
are
using and speaking of specialty
microscopes you
also have a couple of special
microscopes in in your facility right
uh there's only there's a few few of
them uh
in the world so right right yes so our
transmission electron microscopes the
ones
seen behind me here the um titan prices
i would say they're about 450
in in the world which is a very
small number but uh here in new york
city we have quite a few of them
uh so it's a big hub for cryo-em
um and again our user bait our users um
are not anywhere close to the number
that allison mentioned but we do have
uh quite a few scientists here
rockefeller exclusively
only rock polar scientists use our
microscopes
and and they're in high demand of course
because
it's um it's such a great tool yeah
they're both i mean these are incredible
things and to see the
i once went into the cryo-em facility
and saw
the atom of gold and i was like this is
the most amazing thing you know and it
was
yeah and adam you know like i felt very
privileged
and seeing that um and i think
the coolest things that i've learned in
terms of the differences
uh well well let's talk about the
similarities of your
so you both have illumination energies
right and
in the cryo-em case that illumination
energy is electrons
and in the light microscope case that
illumination energy is photons right
and both of them have lenses to help
manipulate
the the the light the illumination
sources so that you can focus on a
sample
but the cool thing that i learned is
that the matte uh the uh i almost gave
away the answer but the the lenses
um for each type of microscope
are different and i'd love for
um maybe folks to talk a little bit
about why that is
so i don't know if anybody feels really
like
compelled to discuss lenses and
illumination energy but i'd love to hear
it
uh sure um yeah um
the well the electron microscope has
uses
electric electromagnetic lenses they're
basically just
coils of metal that can be
electromagnetically electrically
magnetically manipulated
so that they in turn manipulate
the electron beam
and this was discovered in the early
1920s that
electrons can be behaved like
waves like photons and using these
special coiled
uh electromagnetic lenses uh that beam
can be
uh focused into
or can the path of that being can be
manipulated so that it can
act like a light source
um so yeah that's the difference that i
could
my expertise i guess i could explain
yeah i think johanna wins there on
coolness of lenses but
um the lenses inside a light microscope
are made of glass
but they're very complicated um actually
one thing i did have to show you which i
think is cool and i think there was
another question in there about early
microscope so i did want to show you
this
this is a replica of one of the earliest
microscopes
the van liven hook microscope which was
designed in about 1600
and what you do is you stick your sample
on that little pin sticking up there
like a fly
and then there's one glass lens here
behind it and you just look through this
glass lens and you can see
and it's amazing the details that they
could find just with this one
simple little microscope so that's like
the most basic thing from around as i
say from around 1600 and these were
developed mainly by
um spectacle makers in the netherlands
and in germany
um so we hand over to the netherlands
here which is where johanna's coming
from that part of the world
but nowadays the lenses that we use
because the trouble is if you're doing
multiple wavelengths of light
it's hard to bring them all into focus
in the same position
and and so the objective lenses under a
microscope look more like this but
inside one of these lenses there's maybe
10 different pairs or triplets of glass
lenses that have a different shape some
of them are convex some of them are
concave
and they're all brought in together in
order to minimize what we would call
these
aberrations or distortions of the
different colors as they're going
through
i'm sure johanna's lenses also have many
ways of correcting for these aberrations
amazing and and and just to clarify
um oh also before i move into the next
question i also want to point out my
background here
this is a science saturday that we did
about i think this is from 2018
where we had a room and had folks build
the open sourced microscope these are
called fold scopes
and it's paper and lenses that are sort
of
origami together yes there it is there's
the fold scope
so um for folks who are interested in
doing this kind of thing at home
in sort of the the sort of the older uh
traditional way of the closer i would
say it's a little bit more modern than
the 1600s but the ease and portability
is probably
the same so i definitely recommend
checking out these devices
um we do have a question on um
color versus black and white so
donovan and allison when you're using
fluorescent microscopy we can obviously
see
color but is it are we seeing color or
are you adding color
through compute like through the
computer
do you wanna go fit donovan uh yeah sure
so um
so generally when we're using
fluorescence um
yes we actually are seeing color in a
very specific wavelength
but sometimes it's a little easier if we
change the colors to make it easier for
our eyes to see so sometimes
you know it's we're the thing we're
fluorescing is actually dark blue or
something
or and dark blue or blue it might be
really hard for my eyes to see against a
black background
but if i if i change the color on my
computer to say it's like white
it's a lot more clearer that's called
contrast so the contrast is much better
and you can have a better idea of this
of the structures or things you're
seeing inside a cell
so generally yes but you can also just
use white light and it's like then just
you know there's no color but it is also
important to realize that about 95
of the cameras that we use on the
fluorescence microscope are black and
white cameras
so it is a very good question we're
taking real color
real color is coming out of the of the
specimen
but then we're capturing it on a black
and white camera and then we are pseudo
coloring that back again to whatever
color we want
um many people don't realize that
including many of the professors here
but don't let them hear i said that
but and your eyes are actually much more
sensitive to perceiving differences
in black and white than in color so
that's actually
we try and encourage people to display
their images in black and white because
then you can really see
fine differences in the intensities
which you can't see particularly as
donovan was saying if it's something in
blue which is we're not good at
perceiving differences there
but the truth is everybody likes color
right it's prettier so they always want
to show it in color in the end anyway so
that's what tends to happen
now hunk it you don't necessarily have
this problem right because
things are always black and white for
you yeah exactly
yeah we're counting electrons so the way
that our detectors work
they they would actually count the
number of electrons they're entering the
camera
and using uh some computer software it
would try to
convert that into pixels pixel values so
for us
it's a value between zero and you know
whatever the highest value
we use based on the dose
all right so we have um probably time
for maybe one or two questions
there's a bunch of questions out there
on how expensive
are microscopes i will say these fold
scopes are like one dollar
right let's start at the one dollar
so allison tell us how much you know the
general microscope that you use
are you know in in your facility yeah so
most of the microscopes in my facility
would come in the range of a hundred to
five hundred thousand
and then i have three or four
that are closer to a million and there's
one that i
the one that can image something that's
two nanometers in size that would cost
me two million
so i don't have one of those yet
and johanna what what are the costs of
of your titan
and other microscopes well ours range
between um a million to 10 million
um our our big ones back here are closer
to 10 million
um so yes very expensive
extremely um well
i would love to end uh i did not
actually
we learned what han kit and johanna's
coolest thing that i ever saw under a
microscope
so i would love to hear that answer from
allison and
donovan what is the coolest thing you've
ever seen under a microscope
um i can i can start first real quick
yeah
so actually i think the coolest one
maybe make sure
my boss is not here no i'm kidding um
the coolest thing i think um
closely i've seen it under a microscope
would be actually
uh these cells are really cool but
actually seeing um chicken skin cells
um so before you know joining this lab
that i work in
i i worked on studying a little for a
little bit understanding how like your
how how chickens make feathers basically
um
and so we basically use the same idea we
can put chicken skin
cells we can harvest them from the
chicken and then watch how they form
into shapes that would resemble
what a follicle would be like so the bud
where your hair would come out or the
feather would come out
it was so cool watching through
lifestyle imaging um how
how these cells move and form and make
these crazy like patterns and shape
um so chicken skin cells is probably the
coolest thing i've seen under microscope
i never would have guessed chicken skin
cells be the answer to your
to this question but that's awesome and
allison what is the coolest thing that
you've ever seen under a microscope
i'm really struggling here i i can't
think of one
i really can't because there's so many i
mean and i particularly love weird
things i love looking at bacteria and
yeast
and fungus and all of these funky things
rather than just
cells but i can't hone down on one
coolest thing i think i mean the thing
that the things that stick in my memory
the most
are actually things that i've looked at
for years in
regular fluorescent microscopes and then
we bought the super resolution systems
and suddenly you're looking at about
bacteria say which
would just be like a little tiny round
blob even at 100x in a regular
microscope
and then you look at them in a super
resolution and you can see
all these details within it and you know
sometimes you know that you're the first
person who has ever
seen that level of detail in this
specimen because
you've got the first one of these
microscopes and i'm sure johannes and
the hong kid have had
exactly the same experience that it's
like you know you're like oh yeah this
is a really cool thing oh my gosh what
the heck is that i've never seen that
before
and literally sometimes you're jumping
off your chair and i've had some of the
professors just
jumping off their chairs saying i never
knew it looked like that so
i but i'm sorry i just can't think of
just one there's too many
i i am particular i think that's fair i
will admit i'm particularly fond of
still of tardigrades
little water bears i mean who could ever
get over watching
the water bears running around with
their little fists
yeah i feel that well i want to take an
offer this opportunity to thank you
alison donovan johanna and han kit
this has been such a fantastic session
and it has been so
much fun to visit your labs virtually
and i also want to thank to thank all of
you in the audience for your terrific
questions and for joining us on a
saturday morning to explore science at
rockefeller
we hope you had fun i sure did and we
are especially grateful for the andreas
c drakopolis family science and society
initiative
for their generous support of two
rockefellers science outreach programs
science saturday
and talking science which is a program
for high school students offered in
january
thank you again for joining us
[Music]
foreign